i guess like one thing i want to ask is
someone who has been doing it for this
long and who has amassed you know
the amount of subscribers
yeah the cult essentially it's like how
do you see i guess the future of like
content creation on youtube right
because it's like
you know you've obviously hit a point
that a lot of people today have not hit
you know it's it's kind of a because
like i could never relate obviously it's
like where you are right so it's like i
want to know do you reckon as someone in
your position do you see like a future
for youtube content creation because
like you were mentioning how like
recent you know culture around youtube
you're not a massive fan of not really i
don't blame it and i don't like hate
anybody who like plays into it but for
me it's not why i started
yeah my stuff and it's it's all like
idea title and thumbnail first before
anything else anymore and then
yes it is people have like oh i have an
idea how do i do this in like fortnight
because it's like well i have to get
fortnite in there as well yeah yeah yeah
people are just playing the game and
that's fine but i i've never liked doing
that yeah always like if i find a game
that's like like a random japanese
horror game that suddenly gets four
million views and then it's like that
feels better
yeah and yeah seeing that in like the
trending tab feels better than seeing
all the things you don't want to be like
a slave to the seo based yeah kind of
yeah and i feel like i feel like my
channel has been as successful as it is
like i have the privilege of being able
to do whatever i want you played uh the
closing shift i played that recently as
well and that was a that was an
experience that was phenomenal what a
starbucks simulator with horror in it
yeah yeah yeah yeah
but i saw a lot of youtubers playing so
good yeah i didn't know what to expect
and it's just the right amount of jank
to have so much characters right right
oh god yeah because i i started going
back and playing much more of their
other games
and um
that that closing shift one is
definitely their best one like they've
started like
what they're good at basically you work
at like a starbucks uh anyone doesn't
know and uh you have a stalker uh and
yeah that's kind of it okay i saw a
bunch of clips it like it looks
genuinely unknown
in video game history that [ __ ] woman
with the pram yeah i [ __ ] with no
baby in it i i lost my [ __ ] heart
yeah i was ready to drop kick a child
right
what did i just like [ __ ] tip the
pram over but it's also kind of scary
because you play as a woman like at
night in this place with all these dudes
like hitting on you and it's like right
this happens yeah yeah it's not even
like a ghost showing up it's like yeah
[ __ ] weirdo yeah i think it's just
it's got that i i love this game it was
amazing it was so much fun please play
it if you haven't yeah because it'll
have this super seriousness and it
really builds up this tension and then a
guy will come in and start beat like
naked breakdancing yeah oh yeah i saw
that clearly like it's this game that
just in the best way can not decide what
field
it wants to give you and then it like
disarms you though right because you're
scared and then this guy comes in you're
laughing and then you're like oh i
really close up and then the [ __ ] you
jump
it's so the other dude comes in he's
like no need to nihongo jozu
like [ __ ] off is that a natural line
yeah
honestly it's such a it's such a good
game yeah and 90 of it is you making
coffees
right
you know as a content creator there's
definitely that aspect of like this
stalking thing is a little too yeah yeah
a little too close it's just made by two
japanese brothers yeah they just go by
chill as art yeah
but they make really really good games
because their old stuff is all like
supernatural [ __ ] yeah i feel like
they're really getting into like real
stuff yeah yeah and it's so much scarier
yeah
now that you're like you've
your content is so like obviously like
revolved around gaming before has that
changed your relationship with gaming at
all no i game all the [ __ ] time yeah
all right are you a gamer
are you a gamer and i have a girlfriend
impossible
he's also touch grass
i am i mean i still i pick and choose
what i play more
i think this time right still sometimes
i'm like a game comes out i'm like [ __ ]
i should have played that on my channel
it was so good right right right it's
like very hit and miss sometimes and
then
i don't know i just i like having games
for myself i think that's my favorite
pastime yeah and i like how they're made
and i i always kind of wanted to get
into game design and voice work and
stuff so
i think from a mechanical standpoint
i still really like them quite a bit and
artistically and
they're just so good and they just keep
getting better well there's so many
people that's like your recent favorite
game elder yeah oh yeah
okay
surprise surprise
they've played it they won't play it i
don't
the thing is i know i'm gonna like it
yeah that's exactly why i'm not haven't
started yet because you love me berserk
and haven't played have you played yes
like the dark souls games like i love
from but like i know i'll get into it
and that's exactly why i'm scared to get
into it it's like final fantasy 14. like
i know i'll get into it but i know if i
start right commitments out the window
it's worth it it definitely ruined my
life foreign
this time last year you know like in the
middle of the pandemic it was supposed
to come out earlier okay no need to rub
it yeah right we waited so long exactly
it was the perfect pandemic game and now
i'm like traveling in like [ __ ] four
different countries in like three months
or whatever i'm like this is it'll be
there yeah yeah it is definitely a
daunting task to take on because the
first place was like 70 hours yeah yeah
because meanwhile there's a guy who can
beat him in like three minutes
as well he's not even playing eldon
right now yeah yeah he's playing dance
dance revolution and [ __ ] is happening
on the screen he's like coding the game
the zipping of speed runs are like what
what the [ __ ] is the point of this i
mean he doesn't even like them on his
streams he's like i [ __ ] i wish i
could fight things
i wish i could play the game yeah yeah
yeah his bloodborne one is still really
really good and that's all like
perfecting like the craft yeah the
bosses yeah
i guess i guess like final question like
is that you've done already so much of
your career is that is there anything
else you want to do in the future
like you know you've done multiple tours
now you've amassed a massive following
you've met ryan reynolds like i don't
think there's
anything else where does it go from ryan
reynolds
co-starring with ryan yeah i think i
think narrative stuff is kind of where
i'm headed right i kind of had like
projects in the back of my head and
stuff that i've wanted to do for a long
time like stories and right like acting
out characters and stuff and i think
i'll probably get into that right
hell no
it's a big pressure to write books years
ago when everyone was doing them i was
like i haven't lived a life
like what am i going to write i think
you have now yeah
the jack cook book
[Laughter]
you can write a whole chapter on being
friends
yeah i don't know i just kind of want to
focus on the coffee stuff and i feel
like i haven't even like nearly started
cranking that as much as i could right
right just kind of before i was like
taking on too many things and doing them
all kind of poorly
right right a few things and do them a
bit better and yeah
yeah yeah yeah sounds like mine yeah it
sounds like a good path well i guess
well thank you for coming on no problem